a bola sobe jamais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer uma ratoeira
utilizando basicamente papel e para
começar tem que fazer rifas e tubinhos
como vocês estão acostumados a ver nos
vídeos das armas é e eu fiz este diga
sim bem rápido só para não me deixar ter
vida esta semana
e digo isso porque eu vou passar uma
semana de férias na neve
vou tentar fazer isso no board sempre
quis fazer isso e nunca tive
oportunidade é e pronto
surgiu a oportunidade agora comprar
bilhete e agora tem que fazer a mala e
ir embora porque o avião é daqui umas
quatro cinco horas ou seja está tudo em
cima da hora então eu vou fazer um
comentário mas falando que eu vou fazer
porque se eu começar a dizer cola aqui
corta assim é há muito tempo fazer isso
e eu não tem jeito nenhum para isso é
mais cultural é bastante simples vocês
conseguem compreender quase tudo e vou
só agradecer pelo comentário do último
vídeo foi mais um recorde comentários
nunca um vídeo com tanto comentário tão
bom feedback e muita gente contente por
eu ter entrado na cidade o que eu queria
é isso amigos lenta mas também houve
muita isto dizer que eu vou deixar de
fazer vídeos não só então eu sinto eu
vou acabar o o meu ano da escola a
maioria ou seja estou agora nas férias
umas férias em maio mas quando eu voltar
eu vou pra escola mais uma semana ou
duas e vou acabar o ano porque já fiz
tudo o que eu já a planear um precinho
ano é que é assim
nós temos esse trabalho estamos fazendo
um ano e se eu fizer estudantes eu posso
acabar o ano ante o que esse lento e os
sabendo isso consegue trabalhar muito
desde o início do ano para ter esse
tempo para me dedicar ao canal abc
então o canal acho que vai ficar melhor
vou ficar basicamente foca na onu
é o que se lê e vou te trazer conteúdo
diferente que o sempre quis trazer mas
não tive tempo para isso ou fazer
reservas de vídeos que eu preciso para a
universidade em mais ou menos 30 vídeos
ou seja quando foi para ensinar os
vídeos vão aparecer automaticamente e
vai ter vídeos extras enquanto estiver
lá que eu por exemplo tenho carinho por
esta semana fazer um vídeo estava uma
coisa aqui o
o que vem de lá por lá não sei como é
que vai correr é mas basicamente é isso
é estou bastante entusiasmado porque
nunca me dediquei a 100% o canal e agora
vou ter tempo pra isso o canal e depois
de aprender coisas e terminar projetos
que já consegue nunca vos mostrei é isso
estou bastante animado
agora vou panela e eu não sei como é que
isso vai com ele cumpra aquilo a que
muitos lado e eu espero que aguentar o
frio lá e eu vou filmar lua minha gopro
confirma go pro e vamos ver se eu não
sair bem eu mostro segura muito mal e
não vou mostrar porque vai ser assim
mais vergonha né quiser também a
primeira vez os boxes nem como correta a
isso é uma coisa pessoal e vocês têm que
apanhar o rapto mas depois deixando
libertado vez que vocês não vou matar ok
então é isso obrigado investido até a
próxima dia de aula e é